there's so many people that I see like
wait to do something big and then
something gets in the way or they don't
have the health to do it anymore and
like sees the opportunity sees the
moment because you never know what's
going to happen
Runners assemble because on the show
today is a 217 marathoner a world record
holder a transcon finisher and
quarantine backyard Ultra winner Mr Mike
warding it I want to showcase for people
that it is possible I didn't come from a
big endurance background I didn't know
any of these things when I first started
Mike has accomplished a staggering
amount as a runner over the years he's
run seven marathons in seven days on
Seven Continents for which he set the
world record he ran across America he
holds fkts all over the globe from DC to
Israel even completed a race wearing a
Spider-Man costume and oh yeah he's done
all of this while holding a full-time
day job and spending time with his wife
and young children and so like I hope
when people see me now they're like well
if that dude with like the family and
the job and you know all these other
commitments can do it like maybe I can
do it too in today's conversation we
discuss how he started running we talk
about setting World Records his
experiences running across America and
how he balances all of his hobbies and
his athletic accomplishments with his
family and his full-time job I think the
biggest thing is I really want to do it
and and I think a lot of people come up
with reasons why they can't do something
and I look for more reasons why you can
do something it's an absolute pleasure
to have Mike on the show super fun to
talk to I'm grateful he made the time to
come sit down with me and I hope this
episode gives you wisdom and practical
tools regarding endurance motivation
time management and uh just being a
lifelong learner you don't have to go
fast you just have to keep going and you
have to want to keep going if you you
know keep doing the little things the
big things happen
is me and Mike wardy
[Music]
right on well let's just get into it
super nice to have you here I'm so
excited to talk to you thanks I don't
even know where to begin like your
resume is so ridiculous like there's no
way we can go through like all of the
crazy accomplishments uh so we're gonna
try to just I don't know feel our way
through this but I want to begin with
um
DC I'm from DC I know
and you live in Arlington are you from
there your parents live there right my
parents are from Oakton so a little bit
further out and you're from across the
river yeah I grew up in Bethesda yes I
was just in Bethesda last night oh wow
I mean Bethesda now is like a City
compared to when I lived there like when
I was going to school there it was
before the subway even had made its way
out there yet yeah I feel like that's
like the red line maybe I don't even
know my parents live in Georgetown now
they moved to the fun part of town after
I went away to college
yeah it's uh that is a really nice part
of town yeah but it's a great running
City it's such a good City yeah for
running and but I guess you weren't
running then right no uh-uh you were
just swimming I was swimming yeah I was
swimming running came later but I always
enjoy when I go back to DC uh run I mean
I stay with my parents in Georgetown and
then I can get you know right down onto
the tow path or yes do the loop around
the bridges or hit Rock Creek State Park
all of your kind of background stomping
grounds right well and I would suggest
one the next time you're there it's a
thing called the Potomac Heritage Trail
which I don't know if you've ever been
on I don't think so maybe no you would
know so it's pretty awesome so you can
go right across Key Bridge uh loop down
to like Roosevelt Island and then you
just go along the river and there's a
trail that goes all the way out to like
favorite part of that I've gone out like
around Haines Point yes yeah but that's
actually that's a little bit different
yeah so like that's if you like kind of
stuck on the bike trails but this is
like dirt and there's like waterfalls
and like roots and rocks and like oh
it's fantastic I definitely haven't
done that yeah yeah you it's one of my
favorite runs in the world and it's
right there uh right across the bridge
from Georgetown yeah well you'll have to
provide me that route so oh my God yeah
I'm happy to take you too yeah whatever
um one of the things that I think is so
interesting and distinctive about who
you are and what you do is that
um you combine so many disciplines I
mean it's one thing to be
an elite athlete at the top of sport
it's another thing to you know kind of
go off and and do fkts and all these
sort of stunty sort of things that you
do but then on top of that also to have
like a robust professional career and
have kids and a family like combining
all of these things seems so Herculean
like such a Monumental task and you seem
to do it with a lot of
like Grace and ease so before we even
get into like all the accomplishments
like how do you you know how does that
jigsaw puzzle work for you uh I I think
I think the biggest thing is I really
want to do it like I I feel like I've
always wanted to
um kind of meet my obligations and and
still like Chase these like big
audacious streams and goals and so
um
I think if you don't want to do it like
it's it's almost impossible to do it and
and I think a lot of people
um come up with reasons why they can't
do something and I look for more reasons
why you can do something and so like
for me
I I don't know if it's the same with you
but like every time you like went to the
next level you know you'd always have
people that were like oh you can't do it
because of this or this like I remember
when my wife and I got engaged like all
my running friends were like oh your
running's gonna go downhill yeah like
it's it's it's for sure like you're not
gonna have as much time to train with us
anymore and and it only got better from
there and like the same with like when
you have kids it's like oh as soon as
you have kids like you're not going to
be able to be here and and then I'd Rock
up with like two kids in a BOB stroller
and we'd be running like six thirties
you know 10 Mile Run Around The
Monuments or whatever
um and that's just you know how how you
got to get it done if you want to do
these things like you have to put your
head down and and for me it was like you
know getting up early
um and then figuring out ways to like I
knew I had to go to work every day so
like instead of driving I started bike
commuting and then from there I started
run commuting
um and then
I just
um
wanted to make it happen finding the
solutions always looking for the
solutions yeah but when you're when
you're like when you're plotting some
you know in audacious goal like running
across the United States Etc I mean
obviously that's a family decision oh
yeah like how does that look you sit
down with your wife and you're like
here's what I want to do yes yeah pretty
much yeah so I I and my wife's Jennifer
and she's amazing
um but you know first I mean there's so
many different aspects to go into that
and
um
originally it does come down to that
like hey I wanna I wanna chase this
thing you know when would be a good time
to do it and like
and you probably know this because
you've talked to a lot of people because
I've listened to all your conversations
to people that have done this and you
know usually the best time of year is
like March or maybe late February or
like end of August September and like
for me like with work it just doesn't
work like the end of the cargo fiscal
year is September like that's when the
government does all their business that
they're going to do uh and they got to
spend all their money so I can't do like
August September because I just don't
have enough time
and then the kids spring break was in
August or I'm sorry in April and so
she's like well you can't miss spring
break so like my time was
when I get back from spring break with
the kids until I'm done right so like we
looked at that and then I had to cycle
back like a year from that and then I
had to hire somebody for a company that
I work for to cover for you to cover for
me I was wondering like how like I know
you're a partner in international
shipping shipping brokerage Maritime
like I don't even know what that is it
sounds very Jason Bourne yes import
export yeah oh okay what's actually
happening here yeah totally no in DC you
know yeah right approximate to the CIA
like I you know my conspiracy mind is
yeah totally yeah yeah I have a lot of
passport stamps
um no it's um so we do humanitarian food
Aid shipments um so if you ever see
stuff for like World Vision
um save the children
um food for the hungry uh those type of
programs and we do um shipments from the
US and it's kind of export
um additional grains that are coming
from the farmers that are being shipped
overseas and they're used for like
feeding programs or monetization it's
cool yeah so it's really cool and it's a
job that I kind of started
really at the bottom like as the
secretary
um kind of like get your foot in the
door go for like running around like
getting people sandwiches and then kind
of work my way up and now I'm one of the
owners of the business that's cool yeah
and they're cool with you like going off
on these tangents yeah once in a while
as long as somebody can cover your
workload in your absence well and I was
actually working from the road too so
like
um you know there were a couple days
where I'd come in after running for like
20 miles and it'd be like oh I gotta
knock some you know deadline out or
something wow
um which was was definitely
um stressful at times but it was you
know that's if you want to do the thing
you know you gotta you gotta be prepared
to do the work sure so it makes sense
now that you raise money on your
transcon run for World Vision yes given
that that's your sort of it dovetails
into your career and I know Josh your
manager who's here right now yeah he's
been involved with World Vision forever
yeah he really has and it's it's cool
because I got involved with them maybe
2017 one of the things I did was I ran
seven marathons seven days on Seven
Continents right and if you won that you
got uh fifteen thousand dollars and I
was like oh awesome you know like I can
use this to help you know offset the
cost or whatever and they're like it's
for charity and I was like oh okay even
even better I can use that to do some
good and so
um that's when I first got involved with
World Vision I donated that money to
World Vision then and I saw what a good
job they did with it and I was like hey
if I'm going to run across the country
I'd like to do it for you know a good
cause and we were able to raise I think
over 120
000 for World Vision clean water
projects around the world amazing yeah
it's so cool yeah yeah well I want to
get into the transcom but before we do
that let's sort of backtrack a little
bit
and looking at your resume I mean so
overwhelming all the things that you've
done uh 2008 2009 2010 U.S 50k Champion
2008 U.S 100k
Champion uh 50 mile Champion for the US
in 2011 I mean there's so many like wins
and like all this crazy stuff Gobi
Desert 400k then you did the 10
marathons in 10 days on all seven
continents you have the you still have
the record for the seven marathons on
Seven Continents I do yeah I do for now
like 245s or something like that I think
I did yeah including like I I have the
record in Antarctica for the fastest
marathon ever run in Antarctica it was
like two hours 54 minutes
um how do you even do that is there a
road like what does that look like dude
it was so crazy so uh I didn't know
um so we flew down there
um to Union Glacier and it's actually
surprisingly like Antarctica is at uh
elevation so you're kind of at like 3
000 feet which for a lot of elite
athletes that's not that high but for
coming from DC like that's kind of high
for me
um and it was a a Chilean camp
ale was the name of the company and and
basically they had like a 10K track that
they had plowed around the campus and so
it was kind of groomed
um snow but hard packed snow and ice
yeah uh and
it was pretty flat until you got to the
last like 3K and then it like went down
this like dip and then it was like
straight uphill to the start finish area
so you just did that kind of like four
times and you have to do you have to put
spikes on your shoes or do you wear a
normal like Trail shoe or actually yeah
that was really good like so I had all
those questions too and I wore a normal
I run for Hoka so I ran in the Hoka
Stinson
um at that time it was 2017 and the
second time I ran in 2019 I ran in the
Evo methodi which is a trail shoe so
basically just a regular Trail shoe and
when you fly in do you have to then wait
until the weather breaks and find your
window uh pretty much they look for a
window weather window and so you kind of
muster and the first time it was in
Punta Arenas in Chile and then we flew
in and the second time it was in Cape
Town and when you look at the record is
it is it is the record established based
upon how fast you run these seven
marathons or is it the total elapsed
time to do all seven like the travel in
between and all of that and like
knocking them out as quickly as possible
um so the record in Antarctica was just
on that one leg and then the total time
is the time for each race I think I see
the way that it's done because like you
wouldn't know like when you're gonna you
basically still have to finish all in I
think it's 168 hours maybe is seven days
uh and you still have to finish it all
within 168 hours but like if you get a
bad connection or something I don't
think they'd want to take that away yeah
I got you yeah
um where does all of this begin because
you didn't start off as a high school
track and field athlete or anything no
right no not at all I didn't have that
kind of background at all I grew up
playing a sport called lacrosse which
you know is a sport called lacrosse yeah
for a lot of people I guess don't know
yeah yeah I mean growing up where we
grew up that's what kids did yeah I mean
it still wasn't one of the most popular
sports I'd still say football and
baseball and even soccer was probably
more popular
um but now it's like you know there's a
professional lacrosse league we have
Paul Rabel yeah totally yeah dude Part
of That League yes yeah he's a stud it's
cool what he's created
um it'll be interesting to see whether
it can truly capture American audience
Fascination yeah I mean there isn't like
Network TV now the games and everything
and they've really him and his brother
have done a lot they really have yeah
and what's cool is like when I was
growing up like if you wanted to see
lacrosse you'd have to get maybe ESPN2
it'd be like one o'clock in the morning
and I'd be like going down and putting
the VCR tape in to like watch Syracuse
play like you know Cornell or something
but you played division one idea
Collegiate lacrosse at Michigan State
yes yeah yeah so and so that was my
dream growing up was to play division
one and to just see how good I could get
at the sport and
um
Michigan State I'd say it was division
one but it was kind of like not the top
tier so
um you know I wasn't playing at Hopkins
or Syracuse or UVA yeah or Princeton
even at that time was really good
um and I got recruited to play in Denver
but like Denver wasn't even big then
um
but it was it was a kind of a similar
story to you in that like I got
recruited but I didn't get like I wasn't
like getting money because there was
like one scholarship that they split
like a couple different ways right so
like
it was
it was it was a big deal to go away and
and play and for me it was kind of a
dream come true but
um I also knew like you know eventually
that you know I'm not going to make a
million dollars playing across so so so
you your career ends you that chapter
closes and how and when does running
enter the picture uh it entered uh my
junior year of college so I
um joined a fraternity
um uh Pikes I don't know like it was
whatever it was fine and I had a bunch
of uh fraternity Brothers I went to my
buddy Vince boyson's house and was
sitting at uh Easter dinner and his mom
Vicki Boyson had just come back from the
Boston Marathon and she had like the
crinkly little blanket and the Unicorn
metal and it was the first time that I
had ever like met a real person that had
done a marathon and I was just like man
if Vince's mom can run a marathon I can
run a marathon and that was the time
when I new like that moment changed my
life like it was like one of those
seminal moments where you're just like
I I don't know there's so many like
split-second decisions that can change
people's lives and that was the moment
for me where I was like I'm gonna do
this thing and little did I know that
you know I'd end up you know having all
these experiences from that one
interaction yeah it's interesting I mean
tell me more about that because somebody
else could have had that experience of
meeting their friend's mom and just been
like that's cool and moved on with their
life but for some reason a switch got
flicked in you like something got lit up
it totally and and I think it was
because I had started running like when
I stopped playing lacrosse and and Vince
and I were like working out and I was
getting strong and I was like starting
to run like you know 5K around campus
and then like every now and then I'd run
like
I think I could run you know to like the
dairy part of Campus which is like 10
miles and I would just go and run and
then
I'd be like wow I can't believe I made
it that far and didn't need to like stop
or like take a bike back or whatever and
so when I was like oh I'm gonna try to
do this thing but I was like you know
that's one of those like lifelong goal
type things where
you you keep saying it but you're not
sure when it's actually going to happen
and then it kind of crystallized where I
was like oh Vince's mom can do it I can
do it and so like I hope when people see
me now they're like well if that dude
with like the family and the job and you
know all these other commitments can do
it like maybe I can do it too yeah that
does does seem like a very authentic
driver for you like your motivation
really is to
um
share your experiences for the purpose
of of inspiring other people to realize
like these things are within their grasp
yeah I hope so I mean I think like
sometimes the things that I do like
people are like oh man yeah I mean you
get this too it's like there's no I
don't even like driving that far like
um or I you know that's not me or I'm
not built that way and I I hopefully
people can see what we do and say like
well maybe it's not at that level now
but eventually it could be or like this
is a chance to get motivated to start to
do something more than I am now yeah I
feel like it it cuts both ways on the
one hand you go off and do something so
insane people can say well he's got all
this stuff going on and he did that so I
can at least do this yeah but I think at
the same time it also makes it easier
for people to completely dismiss you in
some kind of insane outlier and just say
well he's you know he's whack-a-doodle
like that's you know like yeah totally a
normal person can't do that there's
obviously something you know very
different about this person right but I
think like so many people like I didn't
start out that way right like I started
out like oh I want to run a marathon
like I don't know why I didn't start out
like oh I should want to run a 10K or a
5k or something because I probably
didn't even know that those existed
um
but when you do have that kind of
impetus to get started like it quickly
can snowball yeah so you sign up for
your first marathon yeah Marine Corps or
which one did you do it was Marine Corps
yeah well so I did the MS half marathon
first
uh because I was like well
actually I guess stepping back at
Michigan State I did a half marathon in
a indoor track Like A 1 8 of a mile
track in the middle of winter because it
was on my schedule because I going back
like I said to Vince's mom uh hey you
know it'd be great if you could you know
help me and she was like okay sure and
she basically just went and took a book
like training for your first marathon
and photocopied it and so it was like it
had you know one of those old schedules
it was like Monday run five miles right
Tuesday run six miles and it was like a
40-week build or something and so
whatever it said I just did and so when
it got to like the half marathon day it
was dumping snow at Michigan State and I
was like okay well I I'm gonna do my run
I don't want to do it in negative you
know 20 degree temperatures so I just
went to this indoor track and I got my
buddy Jason to run with me and we
literally like I think I ran for like
two hours or something around this
eighth of a track and I was like if I
can do that I can do the marathon right
and so then signed up for Marine Corps
uh when I got out of school and did it
um with the goal of like
I guess what I wanted to do was run the
Boston Marathon so like when I sent away
to Boston like at the time there was no
internet you sent them like a
self-addressed stamped envelope and they
sent me back the like little pamphlet
and said like what's your qualifying
time and that's when I was like oh crap
like no you can't you can't just sign up
yeah you can't just sign up I was like
wait what and so that's when I signed up
yeah you do Marine Corps so did you
qualify for Boston and your first
marathon I did yeah yeah okay so uh I
knew I had to run three hours and 10
minutes and so I was like okay fine I'm
gonna run three hours and ten minutes
not knowing if I could or not but I
figured if it goes really bad at Marine
Corps my parents can come and get me on
the side of the course and
um I I still remember so vividly like
coming into the last mile
uh at like three hours and I was like I
have 10 minutes to go a mile I was like
no problem like I can do this in my
sleep and then I remember I don't have
you ever run Marine Corps no okay so I
did like when I was a kid in high school
I think I did the the 10K okay same
course that they would have or the 10
miler or something like that okay cool
so like you know like the Finish is like
kind of uphill and it used to go like
you had to go all the way around Iwo
Jima memorial I just remember it
finishes around that Memorial yeah
exactly yeah so with like
10 minutes ago I'm like oh I got this
like so easy and then I just remember it
being like okay like where's the 26 mile
marker and then at like 306 I was like
oh I can see it and then I was like oh
no I have to go all the way around and I
just remember cursing that point too
like being like Oh that should only be
like a minute and it being like two and
a half minutes so I did qualify but it
was a lot tighter than I expected and
like I went like totally in just like
lacrosse shorts and like a cotton
t-shirt and like no lube no taping no
you know just chafed all the you know
everything but all in you run Boston and
you know I Garner from that that you
know this is this is like oh this is
gonna be my path now
yeah it was actually pretty quickly like
I I went to Boston with the goal of like
breaking three hours because I quickly
like determined that if you want to be a
real Runner you should be able to break
three hours and
I don't know why that was like an
arbitrary goal like as a 22 year old kid
I thought that meant something but
um yeah I went with the goal of breaking
three hours and
I think I ran 254 or so so I was you
know pretty pretty much under where I
wanted to be but the thing about it was
it's just Boston just struck me like the
energy the vibe like I think you've been
there before no I haven't actually wait
what I've never seen it yeah oh man
we gotta yeah you should you should
witness the New York New York City
marathon but never Boston yeah I mean
New York's amazing Boston is like oh
it's it's even I mean they're they're on
par with each other so you kind of have
that experience but like I just remember
like the little kids with like orange
slices like standing there so excited to
like hand them to you and like
everyone's just jazzed and like
there's so many good athletes like
everyone there is like qualified to be
there and it's just like this huge
celebration and I was like I want to do
this and so how long between that
experience and you kind of graduating
into this Elite level I mean your PR is
what you're like a 217 Marathon yeah
exactly but that's what 95-96 your first
boss at Boston yeah uh 97 I think was my
first Boston so it's really like a
10-year period then but for sure start
making all these U.S teams and winning
all these races yeah yeah yeah well um
in 2000 so I qualified for three Olympic
trials 2004 or 2008 and 2000 and uh 12.
so 2004 so that's still
seven years of training and learning and
developing yeah exactly and in that time
are you in DC like getting coffee at the
maritime Shipping Company yes yeah I
totally am yeah and I'm running for so
I'm running for
um
the local running stores put uh Pacers
running uh and so I I quickly like uh
got on their
um Team like at first you know I just
walked into the Running store after
running 254 and I was like thought I was
a big deal you know and I was like hey
you know I ran 254 can I be on your you
know running team and they were just
like dude you're not fast enough to be
on our team but they were like hey you
can come to like track workout so I
basically started out in like the you
know kind of third group and by like two
months in I was running with the first
group
um and then I I heard the I overheard
them talking about a race they were
gonna go do this Wawa 10 miler and I was
like I'm gonna go to that race and I'm
gonna beat them all
um
and I ended up going to the race and did
not beat them all but I beat all but one
of them this guy Jeff Van Horn who owns
like Lucky Feet running and we're still
friends but like he still remembers that
day and uh after that race they're like
hey you want to be on our team and I was
like yeah dude and I thought I would I
thought I had made it
one of the things about your career is
that you seem to constantly be racing
right like a lot of athletes at your
level they'll pick their key race and
they'll kind of clear their calendar and
they really focus on you know peaking
for you know one or two times a season
and
from what I can gather it's it's almost
like you're racing it feels like every
weekend you're doing some crazy thing
and you know maybe that's just part of
the whole experience or or kind of part
and parcel of your training approach but
it is very different from the typical
Elite Runner yeah for sure I mean I
think that's the thing that most people
started to learn about me and and
something that I have been known for is
like I'll race 40 or 50 times a year
like
um and it's been less the the last
couple years just because I've been
doing like super long stuff but
um yeah like that if if I could I would
race you know as much as possible so
people that don't know like you ran all
the way across the United States from
San Francisco you ended in Rehoboth
Beach the last mile of of that was like
a 6 10 or something like that right yeah
and then the next day you woke up and
ran a 5k yes in a in like an official
like neighborhood race or whatever and
average like 601s yeah dude yeah and
well and it's funny because I've won
that race like six times or something so
they're like you're coming and I was
like for sure I'm gonna be there and I
was like I I got there with my brother
and I was like I have no idea how this
is gonna go and I was warming up and I
was like
I feel actually pretty good like and so
I I went out and I was like dude you
can't let me beat you and my brother was
like I dropped him and then I started
like picking up people with that race no
I totally did not win but I I did okay I
think I was in the top you know five or
ten
so the point being that you have this
huge kind of diesel engine you can be
the locomotive right that goes all the
way across the U.S but you also have a
little bit of Jackrabbit in you so from
a training perspective like is that a
genetic thing that you've always been
able to go fast and long or do you train
for that specifically or how do you kind
of think about that
um I think I I like to use
um you know both both of the engines and
and I think the run across the country
was I had to be so disciplined like that
was unnaturally slow running for me
um I've gotten better at that over the
last couple years especially with the
fkts and then I've done some of those
you know backyard Ultras like I know you
had Harvey on talk to him and like
Harvey's is similar in that he likes to
race a lot too and he kind of he runs to
and from work and yeah exactly and so we
have a lot of that in common so we've
and we're both plant-based and all that
too so like
um we've shared you know tips and tricks
um but yeah like so as far as I like to
mix it up and I like to keep it
interesting so I feel like if you focus
only on one thing I mean it might be
awesome to get really good at one thing
but I don't think that you continue to
evolve and as an athlete and as a person
so
um I don't mind like not being the best
at something no you seem to have a
beginner's mind like we're gonna get
like you're trying to become a
pickleball professional right like you
do all this other stuff yeah it just
seems insane to me yeah but you know
between the lines I see somebody who
yeah you're not afraid to try new things
you're always trying to master a new
skill and that keeps you kind of humble
and curious right and I'm sure that that
spills over into your running like it
all informs you know the larger kind of
uh you know fully formed Mike wardian
yeah and and as far as like
the ability to to do it I I feel like
um you have again it's going back to
like you have to want to do it uh and
you have to be willing to not have
success and so if you're if you have
those
that mindset going in like you know if I
don't win okay fine but like maybe I did
better than I did the day before or or
maybe the time before or maybe the short
run is going to help me for the long the
long runs and then I feel like the
longer Ultra stuff helps me especially
when I was like running like those fast
Marathon times like when I ran my PR of
217 like two weeks later I ran bad water
and finished third so like just two
weeks later yeah oh my God yeah so like
and like all the people at badwater are
like dude your 217 is not going to help
you you're going to be out here and I
was like I know I know yeah but by
always like having another race a couple
weeks later uh it kind of depressurizes
the whole thing right for sure you're
like all right that didn't go well but
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna be here two
weeks later and we'll try something
different right and and like some people
think like that's a lack of focus and I
just think that's the way that I like to
train and it keeps me motivated so like
if you're not motivated then no matter
how you know well you do at a race like
it's it's going to be hard and like I
feel like a lot of the people and you've
probably seen this in the sport too is a
lot of the people that you know you came
up with aren't doing the sport anymore
or not doing it in the way that they
want or you know I've already stepped
away from the sport so like there's so
many people that used to be my
competitor that aren't even racing
anymore
um so like that's one of the things I'm
really proud of too is like just to have
longevity or you've stayed in it I would
consider myself one of those people
who's not doing it anymore I'm doing
this instead but like that's not a
that's that's your choice right yeah I
mean that choice yeah I mean and some
people like they don't want to do it
anymore right and I don't fault them for
that but I'm still like motivated to see
you know what I can do and yeah it's
stayed fresh for you yeah and I think
like if if I had only like cared about
my 5K time or my marathon time like it
gets hard like it's it's hard to be on
that edge for that long and and only
going for one thing yeah because at some
point you're just you're not going to be
able to make that PR work for you
anymore right and if you have so much
invested in that you're going to be
disappointed or it kind of drains the
joy out of the whole thing right it's
like running with plantar fasciitis like
you can still run with plantar fasciitis
it just sucks it's just not wrong right
like you can train right through it like
I've done it and it it's just sucks the
joy out of every run I mean it's yeah
I feel like most people want to eat
better they want to improve their diets
absolutely have you heard of it I've
heard of it this trips up so many people
we thought hey we know a couple things
about how to do this a few so we created
this thing called the plant power meal
planner that is this beautiful offering
whereby you gain access to literally
thousands of plant-based recipes that
you can totally customize based upon
your preferences your allergies your
peccadillos it integrates with grocery
delivery so all the ingredients that you
need get shipped right to your door so
you can make the stuff that you've
pre-selected and we all could use a
little inspiration and support when
preparing meals for our families in our
busy lives so we hope you join us no
matter what your eating style is we have
our arms open wide and we've saved you a
space at our family table to join us in
eating more healthy vibrant plant-based
meals and if you're looking for the
perfect holiday gift for a loved one
right now for a limited time we're
offering twenty dollars off meal planner
gift cards through December 15th visit
meals.ritroll.com to claim the offer
again for twenty dollars off meal
planner gift cards from now until
December 15th visit meals dot
richroll.com
[Laughter]
so over the years you've gotten you know
quite a bit of press for all the
different things that you've done from
being the fastest marathoner and a
Spider-Man costume and like all kinds of
crazy things but I feel like there was
an inflection point
um in in kind of your notoriety and your
resume with the quarantine backyard
Ultra right when everyone was locked
down all the races were canceled and the
whole world kind of United around this
shared Community Quest where people all
over the world were embarking on this
challenge so talk a little bit about
that for people who don't know what that
is yeah I'll definitely talk about that
a little bit and it's funny because I
didn't even know what was going on until
the week that it was happening like and
I only saw it because my friend Maggie
guterol was doing it and I was like oh
yeah that that thing like I've been
she'd been like oh you'd be good at this
and I was like oh cool and I'd seen you
know the backyard races but for people
that don't know I feel like everyone
that's probably listening to your show
probably does know but maybe not I don't
know but like the backyard Ultra is uh
it's a thing it's kind of like um
uh Sentry Club if you were like from
your drinking days where you drink like
a shot every minute on the minute but
this is every hour on the hour you have
to run
4.167 miles
um and it seems kind of like an
arbitrary number until you realize that
every 24 hours that equals 100 miles so
basically in 24 hours of doing 4.167
miles it gets you to 20 or gets you to
100 miles and then the way that it works
is like everyone starts the race and
then uh the race goes
keeps going no one can quit uh until
everyone quits and there's two people
left and then uh the race can only go
one more Loop until the last person
quits or the second to the last person
what's called like the assist
um and the way that the quarantine
backyard Ultra worked which was kind of
unique at the time as everyone logged
into like their computer uh because
there was everyone was locked down right
it wasn't happening at a particular
place everybody just did it wherever
they were right which was kind of like
amazing and then and most of the time
it's like outside but because it was
quarantined there were some countries
where you couldn't be outside so they
allowed people to be on treadmills or
um there was a woman that was like
running from her sauna in like Sweden uh
like out on this like frozen lake
um there's people like running around
like closed restaurants like I ran
around a 0.4 mile loop around my
neighborhood for
um it turned out to be 63 hours so I
went
um like 260 some miles yeah
um so like and you you won that you were
the last man standing yes the last
person standing and it came down to me
and a guy on a treadmill in like the
Czech Republic right yes and I feel like
that like within the ultra Community or
the running Community people are
familiar with that format of race and
it's gaining in popularity but that
quarantine uh backyard really kind of
made mainstream news because it was such
a beautiful celebration of agency in an
era in which we were all sort of
deprived of agency totally yeah and and
I think there was just nothing else
going on too like in that it's a social
media thing that's what drove the entire
kind of intrigue right and and I think
what was so neat about it too is that
um you did have people like you know
running in restaurants and like you know
they were still in the race you know and
like I'm running around my block and
like people are like no one no one's
going to work so like my whole
neighborhood was out so like I met
neighbors going on yeah and so like the
first day like no one really was out but
like by the second day everyone's like
oh my God that guy's still running
around the block and then by like
halfway through the second day like
people had set up like Aid stations and
like all this like crazy anything to do
yeah no one had anything to do so like
it was awesome you know people are like
and but everyone's still kind of scared
too because it's at the beginning of
covid and so like you know people are
not sure if they should be there or not
and So like
um but it did give you know people
something to follow and I and I think it
was just beautiful like I was following
the other people and I was like I can't
believe she's still running from that
sauna like it's like crazy and then
you're getting the different like
weather too and
um you know it was it was the first
night it was amazing but the second day
got super hot in DC and so like you get
hot and humid like versus like somebody
that's in their like basement you know
like that's it's hard yeah so and the DC
heat and humidity is no small thing no
yeah you know what that's like
um but like just to have so many people
come out and then
um you know mainstream media like it was
on ESPN you know New York Times or not
Wall Street Journal Washington Post and
like it got a lot of coverage yeah it's
cool
um and and that kind of format is only
gaining in popularity like we all saw
what happened last week right yeah the
kind of sealing on what's possible with
that 4.167 Loop is uh is just you know
exploding so these guys from they were
from Belgium right oh dude it was so
baller yeah 420 miles yeah they crushed
the record yeah because it was a big
deal the year before when Harvey I think
was the first to Eclipse 300 uh is that
right it wasn't wrong I think no I think
you're close yeah and
and what's interesting too is like the
format this year I think was they had
like uh national teams so like the US
team versus the Belgium team versus the
French team versus the Chinese team
um and the thing I love about the
the format of The Last Man Standing or
last person standing I should say
because a lot of times women win these
type of things like Courtney's one I
know you've had on the podcast and
Maggie's won and I mean it's it's just
whoever's the stronger mentally because
like it's not that hard to run
4.167 miles in an hour like most people
can walk that almost
um what's hard is like you have to like
do all your nutrition you have to go to
the bathroom and you can't take aid once
you leave the Aid Station and so like
all that part is hard you know you left
out the biggest one though oh the sleep
sleep oh yeah yeah that but you have an
interesting relationship with sleep yes
you don't seem to need that much sleep
no I don't
um which is like a good and bad thing I
mean we were talking Josh and I were
talking on the way up and he's the same
way and um it's it's great but like I I
definitely see the benefits of sleep and
like I've tried to do better with that
and and during the run across the
country like I went from you know my
normal four or five hours of sleep to
like six or seven hours like like no
like I the first like week and a half I
was like I was still doing my thing like
playing my video games and sending texts
and emails that I'll hours of day and
night and then I was just like no I
can't do that anymore so like I mean
maybe there is like a certain threshold
of like exertion where like the sleep
just becomes more Paramount six or seven
hours you describe that almost as if
that's indulgent yeah like four or five
you're you're cool with that I would
just be completely debilitated yeah like
your whoop score would not be where you
want it to be no no but you're fine on
four to five yeah I feel like that's wow
that's pretty good for me
um Matthew Walker would have some
quality words for you he's a sleep
Diplomat like he he's like anybody who
says that they can get by on on on four
or five hours is delusional oh well yeah
maybe that's I don't know but you seem
to be high functioning yeah so far so
good
um although I did read like a bad study
today about how it you know can mess
with your overall like diabetes and
heart disease and all these kind of bad
things but are you just naturally waking
up early or do you set an alarm and just
say I'm only going to sleep four or five
hours oh no no I'm like waking up
naturally yeah um so what do you get up
at like 4 30 or something uh usually
most days 4 45 and then I start my first
workout at like 5 30 and usually that's
like CrossFit or I work with a personal
trainer
um and then I run usually after that
the CrossFit thing is super interesting
I mean that goes back to The Beginner's
mind yeah like I love on Instagram how
you're always you know very
transparently showing all your gym
routines yeah which is unusual for a
runner like they like to show the Epic
you know kind of videos of them running
in a beautiful location but you're like
no it's these little things that I do
all these strength exercises that you
know obviously are contributing to your
longevity because you're like what are
you like 48 now dude yeah right on yeah
totally yeah I'm 48 and yeah I want to
be doing this for a long time and I feel
like that's helped me and I feel like
it's really helped me in the longer
stuff like just being stronger being
able to carry like a heavier pack
um being able to keep form as the race
goes on or the fkt or whatever I'm doing
um and then also it's just like mentally
like it's hard like when you're doing
like the fourth set of like dead bug
plank things and it's kind of like going
into the last like 100 meters of race
you know when there's a person right on
your shoulder and you're like is it you
know is it you or me that's going to
make it to the the line first and I feel
like that really really helps that
strength and stability you can maintain
your form under duress and strain right
anger right more powerfully yeah and
also like
just
I have the ability to just
grind like the ability to just put your
head down and work and I think that
that's really really helpful especially
in a race like the last man standing or
last person standing where it's just you
don't have to go fast you just have to
keep going and you have to want to keep
going so with Crossfit though were you
doing like the classes with everyone
else and they too or did you do that
just alone or with a personal trainer no
I'm doing it with my friend Tom
mayerhoffer and so he has like this
really amazing gym in his house and so
we became friends during quarantine and
so
I've just been doing it with him really
so I haven't gone to like you know
Mayhem or any of the like super badass
like CrossFit places yet which I really
wanted a different culture from the
running culture yeah totally yeah but
it's it's something that I'm excited
about I I was fortunate enough to do
this thing called the Spartan games
during quarantine and got to see some of
the you know Beasts of the
CrossFit world and yeah that's just just
something that I am really impressed
with and I'd like to play around with
for sure have you ever had periods where
you were injured significantly or have
you been pretty injury free no so I um I
had a couple bouts of injury my first
big injury was in 2012 but for the most
part I've been healthy as an athlete my
uh our son Grant has epilepsy and so he
had a epilepsy in 2011 it was kind of
right after I'd set all the PRS and my
marathon and and longer distances 100K
50k uh and he um started getting
seizures and so we were dealing with
that and like my four hours of sleep
went to like 30 minutes of sleep you
know like it'd be like
my turn to check on him or or Jennifer's
turn to check on him uh and I ended up
getting five stress fractures with my
pelvis and five hernias like
simultaneously and that was the first
time I was like oh maybe maybe I'm not
gonna be uh able to be an athlete
anymore but I I did kind of the same
thing I've always done is like okay I
can't run right now but what can I do
and I just like became like the most
insane
um Aqua jogger like I I would just go to
like you I don't know if you know the
pool but like uh Washington Liberty it
used to be called Washington and Lee
yeah high school I know yeah yeah so
like uh I went there and I would just
just Aqua jog for like two or three
hours
um and came out of the pool after that
and some physical therapy and it took
about three months of like letting the
stress fractures heal and then I got
hernia surgery
and then came back and went from you
know nothing to like running like oh I
wanted to run sub six minute miles on a
half marathon and ran like 114 and then
you know started running again and
started winning races again and then the
second Mount was during that Spartan
games I herniated
um my L5 L6 S1 uh disc in my back and I
think I actually maybe sent you a note
about that because I met some people
that were pretty good at getting me
sorted out and so I work with like
MedStar health and oh wow was able to
get my back sorted out we're getting a
note I'll look for that though because
yeah well we could talk about that yeah
yeah totally man yeah yeah so I got
um one I did a bunch of
um you know I'm sure they're probably
having you do like open books and that
kind of stuff to like try to get your
back sorted but
um got that healed and that's actually
when I decided to run across the country
because I was like I've been it's one of
those kind of things that I've been like
oh someday I'll do that and when that
happened I was like I'm not taking any
more chances this is the time yeah right
and did those experiences inform like
your approach to all the functional
fitness and strength training stuff to
kind of stabilize and prevent that from
happening in the future well I think
that that I was doing it already but
that's when I was like hey this is I I
think had I not been doing that I would
have been an even worse predicament and
not able to recover as quickly as I did
so when I got injured at the Spartan
games that was the strongest and fittest
I'd ever been because I was getting
ready to run across the country right
and and I was like then I got hurt and I
was like oh I might not ever have this
chance again and I was like there's no
way I'm gonna risk
not taking advantage of all the
resources that I have have Elite Runners
uh approached you with curiosity about
your strength training stuff because I
feel like
there's a lot of room for for kind of
growth and most Runners especially Elite
they're just doing a lot of the running
and you know the kind of Trope is like
the gym stuff like I you know whatever I
don't have time for that or they're
worried about putting on weight suddenly
they're gonna snap their fingers and
look like Ryan Hall oh my gosh dude he
is like I mean such an inspiration dude
incredible right it's so cool it's and I
saw because he was at that first World
Marathon challenge with me uh-huh and I
thought oh man he's gonna be in my
competition not knowing like I knew he
hadn't run but I was like still he's
like a 204 marathoner like he could not
run and still run like a 230 right it
could probably still Crush you know he
it looks like he's out there running a
little bit these days yeah I know it's
fun man and so hopefully
um someday I'll get to to do some some
fun adventures with him right
um but I think between the two of you
guys because you're you're doing a lot
of strength training but you're
maintaining a runner's physique week and
you're convinced that this is
contributing to your longevity and like
your power and like all of these things
I think that there's there's really an
opportunity for the running Community to
you know Embrace some of the stuff that
you're doing in a in a bigger way well
and it's it's awesome like I every day
have someone that like says like oh man
I do your exercise like at the
pickleball tournament I was at last
weekend I had three people come up and
say like hey man like I I I follow you
and I do your exercises and I was like
that is music to my ears like I love
hearing that and and I think so many
people are so intimidated like either by
the cost or like going to a place or not
knowing what to do when they get there
and so like just to have like something
that's free that they can just be like
I mean it's not everything but it's like
a place to get started right and so like
that's great like and it's making them
better like I I yeah I can't ask for
anything more than that sure
um all right so we have a tradition here
on the show of of interviewing uh more
than a couple uh transcon Runners we've
had Ricky Gates on Who did it
self-supported that's a whole other oh
my God I talked to Ricky yeah right
um Robbie Ballinger hello sedibe I think
Robbie did it in 75 days hella did it in
84. yep correct I don't know how long it
took Ricky but longer because he was
doing his own thing right yeah and when
he did some paddling in there yeah and
he had like a budget he was making a
documentary yeah at the same time
totally yeah and you had to push like he
had to like the hard part for him is he
was going across the desert by himself
like pushing like a cart so like yeah he
had some dark did you watch the
documentary oh man I watched it I read
the book dark moments of the Soul oh
yeah I thought you know when he's he had
to like crawl into a cave for a while
and yeah lick his wounds yeah
um yeah I think he really met his maker
on that one
um but in your case you set this goal of
doing it in 75 days which is how long it
took Robbie
you end up doing it in 62 days right so
yeah 61 in excess to do that you had to
run in excess of 50 miles a day yeah and
I actually did a longer route than a lot
of people too because I went all the way
to Rehoboth and right there was a bridge
I couldn't get across so I had to go
around it and yeah they won't let you
run across the Chesapeake Bay yeah the
Bay Bridge yeah yeah and I called the
the guys in charge of it and he was like
no yeah well most people end in like DC
or New York or they don't go all the way
to the ocean yeah exactly or yeah pretty
much and so and I mean that works but
like I wanted it to be all the way ocean
to Ocean and so I actually messed up
when I planned it I started at San
Francisco City Hall
uh thinking I could just run across the
Golden Gate and put my feet in there but
that's not the ocean so I had to run
like 10K the wrong way the first day to
get over to Ocean Beach oh yeah yeah
it's not that much further but a little
bit Yeah enough yeah I got you and Route
50 is that a typical route or is that
unique to to go that route it's pretty
uh unique I think a lot of people go
um a little bit different
um like some people go like Route 66
other people kind of go a little bit
higher
um so that they can get to New York
because like the fastest route for if
you're going to go for the record or
something you want to probably go like
San Francisco City Hall to New York City
Hall and you kind of go like through I
think it's Yosemite you go a little bit
through there and kind of across that
way
um I wanted to run route 50 because I
called the project running home and I
actually live on Route 50 in Arlington
like Arlington Boulevard uh so I was
like wow I didn't even know that you
could run Route 50 and actually Route 50
ends in Ocean City Maryland so
um a little bit further south so a
couple days after I finished the run in
Rehoboth I went and ran down just to
complete it yeah because you're just so
detailed yeah impulsive yeah yeah
um in looking at like the other people
who have done this uh you know some of
the common themes that come up are like
a greater
you know kind of appreciation for the
beauty of our country but also like the
people because you're meeting so many
different people along the way and there
is this sense that that you know we're
at a kind of unique moment where we feel
divided and we can't communicate with
each other Etc
um but you know if you talk to Ricky or
Robbie or hella they'll say yes we had
some we had some negative encounters
with trucks and cars and a few people
along the way but by and large and for
the most part like it's you know it's
kind of a beautiful experience of of
really connecting with people boots on
the ground you know in all these
different areas as you're passing you
know so slowly through these various you
know areas totally yeah and I I feel
like you also had Mike Posner on right
oh yeah that's right yeah yeah because I
like started following him on I mean he
walked but like I totally didn't even
think about that yeah dude I was
petrified of getting bit by a
rattlesnake in uh Colorado because of
what happened to him
um so yeah you're absolutely right and
it was it's funny because people be like
oh you ran 52 miles a day but really I
ran like five miles at a time four or
five miles at a time like the first week
I was like too aggressive and I was
running like 10
10 miles before seeing my support crew
but like then I quickly was like oh I
need more help
um and you do get a really good feel for
our country and I
I can't believe how Team America I am
right now like I love our country like I
was so shocked at how much Beauty I
found like I've been a lot of places all
around the world all around
um
the country but like that little section
um of the country Route 50 and kind of
like they call it America's loneliest
highway in Nevada like and you're going
through like places like right near like
Area 51 like
um from Ely to I think it's Baker maybe
is like the darkest place in the lower
continental United States so like it's
just unbelievably gorgeous like just
nothing nothingness uh and I read so
many books along the Route but like I
was reading books like Stephen King has
a book where like people are getting
like snatched from like Route 50 like
right where I was running and you know
so it's like you get like all these kind
of different experiences but yeah one of
the best things was like just rolling up
to like a town like we were in I was
telling Josh this actually because he
was watching like top gun Maverick last
night and I was like oh I saw this in
Syracuse Kansas at this theater from
like 1934 and it was like all locals and
my wife and kids had flown in uh it was
the only time I saw them during the trip
and like we went and saw Top Gun like
the weekend it came out after I'd run
you know 50 miles that day right
um and then we had dinner at a local
like
restaurant like the black bison or
something but like the town was
literally like one of those towns from
like it looked like a movie set you know
it was like one strip and it was like
old school movie theater yeah yeah like
State Farm office like restaurant and
then you know Lake that way you know
signed and it was like so many
experiences like that or like uh we went
to this place
I think it's in Indiana instead of uh
you know Dairy Queen it was called Dairy
King it was a complete knockoff of like
Dairy Queen and I don't know if Dairy
Queen knocked off Dairy King or but it
was like shockingly they had like vegan
ice cream they had like whoa vegan like
10 vegan options on the menu like
hamburgers hot dogs like and
literally I was starving but it was
actually quite good like and I was
shocked at how many options I found for
like plant-based Foods along the Route
like I was expecting you know to just
not have a lot of choices and I was
surprised at how many choices there were
yeah the diet thing I mean that's
evolved for you right you were sort of a
long time vegetarian who has been
increasingly more flirtatious with the
in you know the 100 plant-based yes yeah
upgrade yeah great upgrade well and I
guess I'm still not 100 vegan because I
I still uh eat honey and so like that's
why I said flirtation yeah exactly so I
haven't been able to give up honey uh
and I don't know if I ever will but
um yeah I I definitely love that aspect
of my life and that I've been lucky
enough to find you know that I think
when you and I were growing up like the
common mentality especially like playing
a sport like LaCrosse or football or
something is like you need me to be
strong to be able to you know compete or
whatever and I just
started questioning that and and then
you know slowly like
took out one thing and see how I felt
and then took out enough like I stopped
eating red meat in high school and
stopped eating chicken in college and
then well and then you know I was like
oh I still feel good I still feel great
and then I started being like Oh I
actually feel a little bit better and
then my recovery has been the thing that
most people are impressed with and I
definitely feel like that has something
to do with it yeah do you think that as
you continue to make those tweaks in
your diet that that's improving your
recovery or is that like the variable
that you're looking at uh I think it's
something I I think it's just feeling
good like I feel like when I eat the way
that I do like I I feel better and I
also feel like ready for the next
workout or the next adventure or
whatever it might be yeah your recovery
seems like it's off the chain like
you're able to just get up and go go go
go yeah I mean I think that and what's
cool is like I think there's a
and I don't know if it's a misconception
or it's just a common
um mentality about like as you age like
you're not going to be able to recover
as well and I just don't buy into that
like I I feel like I've still been able
to recover just as well as I had before
I think what happens is I just have more
obligations like the older you get you
just have more stuff going on and it
just gets harder to maybe Focus but I
don't feel like the recovery has been
any less than it was when you're
preparing to run across the United
States what is that
training program look like like how do
you approach a goal that massive
it was actually weird
um
so
and maybe this first off I talk to a lot
of people like I talked to Robbie I
talked to I didn't talk to Helen because
I didn't know him at that point now I do
um I would have uh I talked to Ricky
Gates I talked to as many people as I
could
um a guy named Phil McCarthy I don't
know if you know him or not
he's like a New York based guy
um Jason Romero who's another guy who's
run across the country
talked to
um yeah just anyone I could that that
had done it and I joined like a Facebook
group like U.S transcon uh-huh I think
Robbie talked about that yeah exactly
there's a lot of it everybody wants to
help right yeah this Collective wisdom
about right common mistakes and like
don't run on I-70 in Colorado or you
know you're going to get booted off like
I think Robbie actually had to jump like
a thing when the cops came or whatever
and I don't know yeah so I tried to talk
to as many people as I could and
what I realized is there's it's almost
like I think people think when you're
getting ready to run 100 miles like
you're going to be running 100 miles in
training and that's not really the way
that it works for most people
um and so I just realized like I'm not
going to ever be able to do
like my friend Pete castellnick I talked
to also who has the record
um and he was like waking up and doing
like a marathon every day right and I
was just like I just don't that's not
what I want to do and so I started doing
a lot of cross training I did a lot of
CrossFit doing a lot of like strength
training I I wanted to put on like three
or four pounds of muscle like usually
I'm like 140 to 142 pounds and I wanted
to get up to like 146 147
um just so I'd have something to give
away uh as the Run went along
so I I wanted to put on weight uh I
wanted to do one kind of simulation race
so I did a race in Sri Lanka called the
ultra X Sri Lanka which was like a
five-day stage race where you
um are running anywhere from like a
marathon to like 40 miles
um
in extreme temperatures because I knew
like I'm gonna not have the options yeah
I'll have and also like I wanted to to
get the heat and humidity because I knew
that we had a trip with the fam like you
were saying like how did you make it
work like we planned a family trip to
the Galapagos with the family because I
figured like once a lifetime trip family
will all go to the Galapagos uh we'll
have a great time and then like no one
will need me for a couple weeks and then
that's three weeks into the transcon and
then by the time people are like oh
where's you know like I'm starting to
miss my dad like I'll almost be done and
uh so like kind of got all that lined up
um but I didn't do a ton of running I
actually did less running than I
normally do knowing that
I kind of had a huge base of years and
years of just stacking runs and workouts
and the last it was ridiculous but like
you and I both talked about earlier I
was like I love to race I I turned down
more races in
amazing
locations and opportunities than I ever
have in my life because I was like is
that going to get me across the country
no then I'm not gonna do it so it was
like I think that was for me one of the
hardest things was like running less
than I want to because I don't want to
injure myself or put myself in a in a
bad spot training wise and then
putting on putting on weight knowing
that you're gonna hopefully give it back
to the running Gods which is what
exactly happened like there's no way
that you can eat as many like when you
say like someone like Michael Phelps
eats like 13 000 calories a day or
something like I don't know how many
calories you've tried to eat a day but
like no that just it's a that's a job
like that sounds it's challenging and
not fun it's just not fun like by the
end of the transcon I didn't want to eat
anymore like I I if I could have taken
that fuel from The Matrix where it's
like everything you need in like a gruel
and you could just drink it and it would
be done like I would have done that 100
of the time how much weight did you lose
like when you completed it were you
significantly lighter yeah so I started
at 146 and I finished at 1 34 or so
um that's not too bad though it wasn't
too bad yeah and and it quickly came
back so like right I but I sacrifice
advice like I all my little muscles that
I had built up from Crossfit were just
evaporated like like I was like oh no my
little little biceps going across the
country but I gotta turn turn in my
CrossFit man card yeah pretty much but I
like that that notion of just becoming
strong stable and fresh you have this
huge base and the discipline as you
mentioned earlier was really about
holding back because you're so used to
running fast and far it would be very
easy for you at least early on to kind
of overdo it and dig a hole for yourself
so just being like really cautious and
and like meeting out the days like you
know in a very methodical way and kind
of
building the fitness as you go like I
talked about
James Lawrence here in cowboy he did
like 101 iron yeah yeah he was like he
barely did any running at all before
that he was like I just all I'll get fit
for that as I go because it's so long
there's only so much I can do to get
ready for it yep and we can debate the
wisdom of that but you know I can see
the logic yeah and and I that being said
like we didn't touch on this but in
2019 I did a test where I ran across
Israel and set the fastest known time on
the Israeli National Trail 600 miles or
something right yeah it's a thousand
kilometers or so and I did it in about
10 days so like 100 kilometers a day
and I knew like what that meant like and
that to me was like like if you want to
go for the real record like to run
across the country that's like 72 miles
a day and that's like
that's those are big days like and going
across Israel like I had days that were
like 20 hour days and you're going up
and down mountains and navigating and I
was just like
I know what that means so like when I
hear people say like oh I'm gonna do it
in like 40 days I'm like you do you
don't even you you don't know what
you're saying because like it's not like
the running's one part of it but then
there's like where you're gonna stop the
RV right where are you gonna get food
like who's gonna do the laundry like
who's gonna like how long does it take
for you to tape your feet like do you
know how long it takes to tape your feet
in the morning like are you gonna make
yourself take a shower and then every
night I was doing a Facebook or
Instagram post so like that was like an
hour hour and a half every day trying to
remember what happened during the day
you know who threw a hamburger at you
like the person that stopped their car
to you know wish you well or you know
try to run you off the road or whatever
happened yeah you were pretty good about
that uh you know always taking photos of
people that were running with you like
everywhere you went it's cool and even
though you did this in 62 days you still
managed to go see Top Gun and go to
Dairy King and like read a book here and
there I read like 30 32 books wow yeah
like before you went to battery night no
I was listening to audiobooks audiobooks
okay yeah so I was listening to
audiobooks I was listening tasking yeah
I was listening to your podcast a lot
like you thank you again because you
guys helped me get through it for sure
like it was that's cool and especially I
love the long form because like you
really get into it with people and so
it's you know I remember one day in the
middle of Nevada listening to you guys
talk and I was just like
this is so awesome like I can't believe
like I because I was thinking of like
because I and I also read a bunch of the
old books like you know Tales from the
breakdown Lane and like my life walking
around the country and stuff and I was
just thinking like those guys were like
going to pay phones like to check in
with their family like I'm like on my
airpods like calling my wife like she's
listening to cars like Zip by me like
freaking out you know every day and then
eventually by like two weeks in she's
like uh there's another truck I was like
yeah another truck but like I had those
kind of resources that people before me
didn't have yeah and the GPS everyone
knows where you are all the time for
sure RV yeah yeah so did you have like
what was the crew situation did you have
multiple people coming in and out or
like one guy who was with you the whole
time yeah so I I I hired a guy
um so Eric Bells is his name he and that
was the other things like how do you get
crew so like I had to figure it out so I
uh my friend Carl Meltzer I don't know
if you know him like speaker but I know
who he is yes yeah so like he set the
record on the Appalachian Trail and uh
he's run like the Pony Express Trail and
so
um I talked to him and it was it was
lucky man it was like my buddy from
Michigan State said like hey my friend
uh Cruise people and I was like whatever
you know like this guy Crews people like
mother of the woods like 10 okay or
something and he's like no no he Crews
like real people and I was like okay
sure give me his name and so I call Eric
and I'm like hey man uh I heard you crew
people he's like yeah crew people I was
like oh cool like who have you crewed
like what are we doing here and uh he's
like yeah I crew like Carl Meltzer I was
like really and uh so I text Carl I'm
like Carl do you know some guys yeah
yeah
and he's like dude Bells yeah hire him I
was like okay cool he's like oh okay and
so you got the guy so I got the guy and
then my dad it was just gonna be my dad
and I
um and then my brother and I were like
dude that's not gonna work my sister and
she's like you know you can't just be
with Dad by yourself for like two months
and I was like okay we should get
somebody else and so I was so glad I did
because I mean my dad's awesome but like
that's a lot of work for anyone like
just one person like that's just
impossible so like I had my dad uh Eric
and
um
um my Dad's friend and he and my dad
would kind of like be there and not be
there but Eric was always there so he
was kind of my crew chief and you had
some scraps with people throwing
hamburgers at you and trucks trying to
drive you off the road like what what
was the you know what were some of the
dramatic uh that was definitely
traumatic like I think every day there
was like drama as far as like every day
yeah every day
um with people you know just I think a
lot of it at times it's just people
being surprised that you're out there
and it makes them uncomfortable and then
they kind of get mad that they feel
uncomfortable and then they're like all
right well I'm gonna you know Buzz you a
little bit closer than I have to or have
you ever been cold rolled what does that
mean oh my God it's this thing I didn't
even know it existed until I got to
Indiana but basically like a diesel
truck they can get up next to you and
they downshift and it blows like this
all the exhaust comes out yeah the black
smoke comes out and if they do it right
they can actually spray like diesel out
the back uh of the like exhaust at you
uh I did not know that was a thing but
it is a thing so doing that on purpose
yeah so like doing that on purpose oh
cool oh it's it was crazy I had one
little old lady it was like six I'd
start every day at like six in the
morning and go to like try to end about
six at night so like 12 hours of running
or walking or whatever
um and it was like 6 30 in the morning
this little old lady like comes around
the corner sees me and just flicks me
the bird like I'm like it's like 6 30 in
the morning man like how like what how
can your day be so bad already that that
you know you're just in a bad mood about
something so but I I've said this to a
few people like and I think you
mentioned this but like for every you
know two or three people that were
terrible or or you know not happy that
you're out there there was 20 or 30
people that were so stoked that you were
there and
um you know we had people come out like
that had been looking forward to this
like since I started you know and this
one guy had passed away on the operating
table came got revived came back and
decided he wanted to run with us so like
he showed up and
I guess he had like
told us at the beginning like hey I just
want to run a mile with you and I was
like dude you're going to run as many
miles as you want so like why don't you
set the pace so like that whole morning
like he set the pace and I just stayed
behind him and he ran 10K with us like
wow he had not been able to like he
wouldn't he wasn't even alive like three
months before that like he passed away
and came back and we had another guy
with afib that came out to West Virginia
and looked for the steepest climbs on my
route because he's like I can't run with
you that long but he just wanted to hike
with us up one of the climbs like stuff
like that that's cool dude it was yeah
it was everything I hoped it would it's
so cool yeah I mean I just know from
watching Ricky's documentary like the
most
you know heartwarming uh you know
sequences are when he has these
incredible encounters with random people
like the guy who want to give him money
yes oh my God we had that so many times
really yeah it was amazing and we
actually had a woman who sent her mom
and dad who they she knew they were
driving out on Route 50. she sent them
to find us and to donate money but like
they weren't sure they wanted to donate
the money
um so like they were like quizzing us
about where it was going to go and stuff
and I was like man if if you don't want
to it's fine you're exactly just forty
dollars gonna end up at Dairy King yeah
exactly I was like it's fine you don't
have to vegan ice cream yeah exactly
World Vision can wait no actually there
is a better story so on the have you
ever ridden the KD Trail uh it's in
Missouri it's it's basically like um the
CNO Canal but it's in Missouri and
what's so cool is like and you you
probably see this when you go places
like I think one of the things I love
the most about our country is like
people are so proud about where they
live and they take so much pride and
they have so much reverence for it like
if you go anywhere near Missouri they'll
tell you about how cool the KD Trail is
and like they think it's like the most
unique thing in the world and it is
pretty unique but it's just the CNO
Canal it's like basically what we have
in DC you know it goes from
Georgetown to Hagerstown right and so
like it's awesome but it's like it's
it's similar to what there is around the
world but like they had like the the
head of the Park Service come out and
meet me they had like the the mayor of
Jefferson City which is the capital of
Missouri come out but like one of my
favorite experiences is like I had the
these uh little old lady and man come
out and the guys like hey you know we
want to support you our son's like a big
fan you know we came out they like you
know waddle up in their like hokas and
they're like we were our hokas I was
like no way that's awesome and he
reaches in his wallet to give me a 50
Bill and she reaches over and slaps his
hand she's like no no and and and so he
you know gives me like a ten dollar bill
and what I loved about that interaction
was like it didn't matter that you know
they didn't give us you know 50 bucks or
whatever what was you could just see
like that that's been the relay
relationship and like he's the like big
spender you know like he's like he's
coming from the heart yeah he's like the
head yeah exactly yeah but like they
make such a little perfect couple you
know and like those interactions like is
something like so unique and something
that
you wouldn't get a glimpse of someone's
life if if I hadn't you know been doing
it in that way yeah and you ran into
some transcon Runners along the way
right like other people that were doing
it or coming from the other direction
yeah I uh I ran well I had two friends
doing it so Richard Donovan who does the
seven Marathon seven day seven
continents he was doing it and so we
actually met in Missouri like right off
the Katy Trail he was going east to west
and I was going west to east uh and then
I had another friend that was going kind
of like a northern route but I had a guy
that I ran into again I think it was in
um maybe Kansas and it was in the middle
of nowhere dude it was like 11 o'clock
in the morning like
between two towns but like far like 20
miles and it was just kind of hot like
95 degrees and I see this guy shirt off
stroller
like I'm like there's no way that guy's
just out for a run like around his block
you know like like out in the middle of
nowhere with a stroller yeah I'm just
like that's got to be another transcon
Runner and I was like Jennifer I'll call
you back and I like run across the
street and I'm like dude are you running
across the country he's like yeah are
you running across the country I'm like
yeah and it was like dude I needed to
see somebody else doing this and I was
like where'd you come from he's like
Norfolk and I was like oh no hey Norfolk
Virginia he's like yeah
I was like how long ago did you leave
and he's like I don't know 15 days and I
was like what like I was so excited
because I was like going across the
western states like you could be in
Nevada for like
seven or eight days right and so I was
watching my friends go from east coast
to West Coast and they'd be like Oh I'm
in Massachusetts now I'm in Pennsylvania
now I'm in Illinois and I'm like I'm
still on Nevada like right and then
going across Kansas like everyone is
like you're gonna hate your life and I
actually loved it I thought it was
amazing but it's a humongous State like
I was running across Kansas for nine
days like just insane never ending yeah
I I can't remember who it was it was
either Robbie or or hella talking about
like once you when you go west to east
after you get over the Rockies and then
you're going you know you have these
long flat expanses Etc but you kind of
think it's this slow downhill all the
way to the east coast and then you hit
like the mountains around West Virginia
and it destroys you right yeah I don't
know if Route 50 like where that
actually you know that tracks with what
these guys were talking about but they
said that was like a soul Crusher
because you kind of you're you're
getting really close and then it's like
this wall that you hit that's totally
true yeah and I knew that going in just
because I from around here and I think
so many people like think the Rockies
are so imposing and they really are like
there was big days and big climbs but
the little climbs I mean that's what
makes Barkley so hard like I've done
that race a couple that's the one thing
that yeah you haven't cracked that one
no dude not even close like I haven't
even made it a single Loop yet in time
so but like I know like the short little
climbs of Appalachia and East Coast are
are legit and I knew that going in and I
was like I I think my route had a
hundred and thirty some thousand feet of
elevation gain and I got to like West
Virginia and I was like at 90 000. I was
like well there's a right there's 30 000
feet coming up in the next couple days
30 of your grade remaining yeah what
what was the hardest point I mean did
you have like a some breaking moments or
yeah I mean I think there were a couple
hard Parts like I'd never been away from
my family that long so like that was
really hard for me like I wasn't
expecting it to be that hard just from
traveling the world and being gone on
all these Adventures
um I wasn't expecting to miss them as
much as I did
um that was that was hard but like as
far as like physically like each and
every day was so hard like that last
like
10 miles every day was like finishing
100 Miler like it was really really hard
I was not expecting that I figured kind
of what we were saying earlier is like
as you go you're just going to get
stronger
um and stronger and stronger and
stronger what I didn't realize is like
the longer you go you're getting so
strong but you're also just getting so
much more tired so it's like the
strength it's almost balanced out or
like and some days it could be an kind
of unequal
um but I think the worst thing was I had
about 500 miles to go and a Truck veered
over the white line and tried to like
scare me hit me I'm not sure and I had
to I was in the middle of a stride and I
had to stop running because he got that
close like if I would have kept swinging
my leg I would have crashed into his
bumper and so I had to like kind of Veer
off the side of the road and at that
moment I felt my hamstring pop and I was
like oh man oh this is not good and I
still had 10 miles to go for the day and
everyone's like yo you should just get
in the car and I was like no man I'm
trying to average like 52 miles a day so
I was like I'm just gonna lock it in
um and that was a really low point like
I couldn't put weight on my on my right
leg I
um
yeah I was I was like so mad because I'd
been so disciplined like every day not
overdoing it you know taking care of my
feet taking my socks off every time I
come into the car like putting on
sunscreen like
putting on ChapStick like doing all the
little annoying things to make sure that
I get there and to have somebody kind of
ruin that or potentially ruin that for
like no reason that I could see other
than me just being on the road like I
was really just kind of mad at the world
and life and and
yeah I didn't know if I was going to be
able to run so how did you bounce back
from that just get get in the car get
massage or how did that get worked out
so you could bounce back and get back on
it well so
instead of like it taking like two hours
to go
10 miles it took like three and a half
hours to finish it off for that day I
got in the car I called my personal
trainer my guy Jesse and I was like
Jesse what do you think he's like is it
black and blue I'm like I don't know I I
can't I can't put weight on it I can't
even like get out you know like I don't
have you ever been that hurt where you
can't like take your shorts off you're
like
this really really hurts
um I I basically
like cried myself the bed basically and
like was like I I don't know what to do
like I don't want to he's like don't
stretch it anymore don't really do
anything if it swells up like he's like
try to put some ice on it which I did
but he's like I don't know if that's
gonna really help and a lot of times I
don't know if you do this but if I turn
my ankle or stuff I actually just leave
it and don't put ice on it because I
want the blood flow to pump through
there uh or you do like a little bit of
ice and then let the blood come kind of
rushing back so you gotta get like that
burst of
um blood flow to it and I woke up the
next day and it was still kind of
hurting as I was like taping my feet and
putting my shoes on and I was just like
I'm just gonna walk you know for the
first hour and see how it goes
um and then I came to like a kind of a
slight downhill and I was like well
we're gonna see how this goes and I just
started running
like shuffling really not really running
and I was like I don't feel it hurting
and then
I
continued to run the rest of the day and
then if I'd run I don't know if you've
ever done like a hamstring but when I've
done it like if you push too hard like
it starts to twinge as soon as it did
that I would just start walking and I
just did that for the whole day and it
just sort of sorted itself out yeah
you're lucky dude so lucky yeah like I
was just thinking like 500 miles of
walking this is going to take instead of
taking 500 miles would be about 10 days
this is going to take 20 days right or
more like I'm right like that's just
gonna mean like I'm not gonna finish
anywhere close to where I want to finish
um but I I mean I felt like I could
still walk on it but like I was like oh
this is just going to be terrible
what I extract from that is that the
little things are the big things it's
all about like you know the fact that
you race so much that you know for the
most part without you've been able to
like sidestep injuries and you know have
all these incredible achievements it's
really a function of consistency like
waking up early showing up every single
day paying attention to those small
things the details whether it's taping
your toes or making sure you got Lube in
your you know in your armpit or whatever
you know your your inner thigh or
whatever it is like those tiny things
this effort to you know control all the
other all the variables that are within
your control
and yet at the same time in the story
you just told like you can't anticipate
everything there's always going to be
something that can derail you but when
you're paying attention to as many of
the things that are within your control
as possible that's really kind of the
the path towards achieving achieving the
big goals are about like doing the tiny
little things every day yeah the
annoying little things like the things
you don't want to do right like no one
wants to wake up an hour early to tape
their toes like at least I don't like
that's not what like makes me excited or
like making sure that you've gone to the
bathroom three times before you show up
at the start line and it's not like I
started out doing it this way like I
think I think one of my favorite talks
that as far as like the audience was
like I was at the San Francisco marathon
and they're like you know you've done
this talk a million times I'm sure where
it's like you know tell me your race day
tips and it's like you know wake up two
hours before the race and you know eat
and then you know what do you eat uh
Bagel or whatever it is right and I was
like you know I'm gonna do a different
talk today I'm going to tell you all the
things I've done wrong like so I've the
reason I can tell you what to do is
because I've done everything wrong like
I've shown up with races with no shoes
before and like had to borrow my buddy's
shoes because I was like oh I'm for sure
put them in my bag and so now if people
follow me on Instagram they see like lay
out my kit the night before because I've
showed up without safety pins I've
showed up without the right chip you
know in South Africa where you have to
buy the chip ahead of time you know I've
um rocked up to the race uh without Lube
in the Gobi desert and I was like
knocked out of the race because I had
gastrointestinal problems and had it not
been for some guy on a moped driving by
with like diaper cream I would have been
you know still in the Gobi desert
somewhere so like like I learned all the
the things to do because I've done all
the things wrong in the past and so
like if you keep making mistakes and you
don't learn from them that's a problem
but if you realize like oh maybe I
should lay my kid out the night before
so that I you know don't show up without
right it's no big history it's like
basic Common Sense kind of things right
like planning ahead right but like going
beneath the surface on all of that like
I I'm interested
that stuff's all fine but like what is
it that's that's like driving you like
what's behind all of this that is
compelling you to tackle these
challenges like what are you trying to
learn about yourself or what is it that
you're kind of exploring internally like
what is the you know what is the the
teaching that you're extracting from all
of these Adventures
um I think at the base levels I want to
see if I can do it
um I want to see if it's possible for me
and if it's not possible now is it
something that I want to invest in that
it will be possible in the future so but
why is it important to you to try to see
if you can do these things
I don't know I think
I think I'm always questing to be better
like I think I wanna I wanna get the
best out of myself and and I and I feel
like right now it's through these kind
of big ridiculous challenges
and I think
I want to I want to showcase for people
that it is possible like I I didn't come
from a big you know endurance background
I didn't know any of these things when I
first started like I started like so
many other people with like a little
goal and then from there I was like
maybe I can do something else and you
know eventually I'll reach something
that I can do and then you have to
decide if you want to
if you want to keep going and try to do
it like right now like please yeah like
Barkley right like I know that like it's
possible people have done it but like is
it possible for me why is that so you
know intractable like what is it about
that race that just cracks everyone
um I think the thing well for me I don't
have a lot of the the
the
best skills for it like I think like you
have to be really
there there's a couple ways I think you
can do it or like it looks to me that
you can do it like you can just keep
going to the race
so that you just put the time in like
like I said it's kind of like pledging
right like you just keep showing up and
like eventually eventually you get hazed
enough where you are like okay I know
where the book is and or I know what I
know what he means when he says like the
coal Road or like go past the sofa on
the lily of the valley like I know it
all though like
flowers are they just talking about and
so I've learned the Lexicon I've put my
time in I know all the candy Trails like
you know the regular trails and I know
what bird Mountain looks like and then
you just have to get lucky with weather
like I think the biggest thing for
Barkley is like getting decent weather
because if you get the fog that comes in
a couple times when I've been there like
I'm not seeing you like and so the only
way to get through it is to know the
course really well be really incredible
at navigation
um and Get Lucky with weather and then
you have to have the fitness so is that
something you're gonna go back to
uh I'd like to yeah I mean I think
um but if you don't want to do the work
I don't think you should take a spot
from somebody that's willing to do the
work so like if you're just going there
just to like say that it's like oh I did
Barclay like I don't want to I don't
want to take someone's spot unless I'm
ready to like fully commit yeah so what
are the the big goals that are looming
out there that you're thinking about
right now
um yeah I think this is actually one of
the hardest things right like
coming off of like a run across the
country like everyone's like oh what's
next and
and so my pad answer that and it's
something that I wanted to do actually
before the run across the country is the
Appalachian Trail that's like really
near and dear to my heart and like
that's something that's uh gripping and
that it's
feels impossible but like when I was
running across the country and I ran
past the distance like I don't know if
the other people that you talked to I
don't remember if they had said this or
not but like when I had little
checkpoints like I went a thousand miles
or I went uh 2 000 miles like or crossed
into a state like you get a kind of a
boost yeah I got a huge rush when I was
like I just ran the entire Appalachian
Trail distance you know like not the
vertical right because the vertical was
like way more than what I was doing but
like just to know that you can do that
distance
um that was impactful for me and that
was something where I always like said
to my wife like hey if I ever get fired
from my job I'm gonna do the Appalachian
Trail and but now I'm like the owner of
the company so they're doing these crazy
things you're never there yeah but
you're a partner right can they even
fire you yeah well I'm actually one of
the owners now so like I have to fire
myself I go out of business before they
can fire you but like right so like
um so like the Appalachian Trail and
then you're the you're the reason why we
have
um
what's it called uh
uh you know all these issues with uh
supply chain right it turns out it has
nothing to do with the pandemic it's all
because you're just not at your desk
yeah right now these cargo ships are
like backed up and they're like where's
Mike where's Mike we can't we can't come
into Long Beach because we can't get
Mike on the phone yeah no
um no that was actually great like that
was actually one of my biggest fears was
telling our big client like um it's a
company called mercline limited who's
like I I don't know like the biggest
right yeah they are the biggest yeah and
so like I was like oh man I really want
to do this and they're like that's
amazing we want to help you and I was
just freaking out about that
conversation and so I was really happy
that they came on board
um but yeah like as far as goals like
the Appalachian Trail and then I have
this ridiculous interest in
and this is really far out there for me
but like doing like you've done some of
the big swims but like a like a swim
around Manhattan I think would be kind
of cool like people do that one I love
that one that's that's definitely on my
list yeah like I think I and I'm not a
good swimmer like you're a good swimmer
like for me my longest That's The
Beginner's mind thing like you would
want to do a long swim yeah not a
swimmer yeah I'm I'm very bad at
swimming
um as far as like form and like I think
the longest swim I've done is three
miles and it took me longer than running
like a marathon like it was like two
hours and 25 minutes to go three miles
like in the ocean but like still and I
really wanted to do the nine mile swim
but I freaked out like I was like oh you
have to get a crew and like you know you
need like a boat next to you or whatever
uh and then I want to row across the
Atlantic like that's something wow like
and so I've been talking to a friend in
Arlington that I won't name because he
like hasn't told his wife because I like
called him about it and I was like dude
do you still want to do that and he's
like yeah let me go outside though I got
to walk the dog because I don't want to
tell my wife yet well I got a few guys
that you can talk to about that who have
some experience with that kind of thing
yeah I don't know anything about that
world yeah but I think that would be
really cool especially like
that's like for real Adventure like and
I feel like that's like what I'm looking
for like at those Adventures like and
there's a lot of other things like I
want to like climb Everest but like my
wife and I have a deal where I can't do
that until the kids are 18 so that's a
good rule yeah I think I saw a quote
where you said you were asked this
question and you said I have so many
things I want to tackle next I want to
row across the Atlantic and I want to
run the Appalachian Trail I want to do
the Pacific Crest Trail run across all
the continents and then also run on the
Moon yes you actually said that yes yes
so you're dreaming big my friend dude
well I think if you just keep putting
out so I've been saying that for a long
time about running on the moon or like I
would take Mars but Mars a little bit
further away but yeah I think
I think that could be in really cool and
I I mean it's not possible yet but I
don't know if it's going to be that far
off
time will tell yeah well that's Jeff
Bezos yeah or Elon yeah
um where does becoming a professional
pick a pickleball player fit into fit
into all of this is because that seems
to be the thing your most fired up about
right now oh my God I'm so lit up on
that yeah I just
um was able to partner with a company
called Yola so they're sponsoring the
best players in the world and so a guy
named Ben Johns you are a professional
then you're a professional well your
sponsored yeah but it's very it's very
um early stages for sure and I'm I'm
definitely like I don't know if you know
like how the rankings go in pickleball I
know nothing so it's like tennis it's
like 2.5
3 3 5 4 4 5 5 is like you're really good
almost Pro and then kind of above five
your pro so I'm like three five four so
like you know very early stages but yeah
I'm I'm spending a lot of time playing
pickleball and Drilling and like working
I'm with a group called The Arlington
iron paddles and there's like 70 people
in the group and everyone wants to be a
pro so like we're working really hard so
like I'm learning shots and you know
meeting people to drill at like seven
o'clock in the morning paint paying like
20 on the weekend to go get my butt
kicked in these little tournaments that
we're hosting and it's weird how that's
become such a thing in such a short
period of time like it went from nothing
to you know I I have so many friends who
are obsessed with playing it like how
does that have like it's weird how
culture happens that way like yes it's
just this thing percolates up and then
suddenly we all agree that like this is
a cool thing we all should be doing it
yes it's so weird and especially when I
first heard of it I was like oh that's
that sport the old people play right
right like paddle board tennis or
whatever yes exactly or or like Ping
Pong or something or or Bocce like I
play in a Bocce League also like
um of course you do
what yeah
um I don't understand the time schedule
that yeah you fit all these things in
it's it's it's I don't know it somehow
it works
um but as far as like pickleball like
it's it's easy to learn but hard to
master it's kind of like I like I don't
know if you saw it but I also like play
chess and I'm like trying to get better
in chess and so like I I you know find
these little hobbies and and kind of go
deep as I can on them and
um with pickleball like I feel like it's
just it's almost I guess Josh and I were
talking about this too is like somebody
it's like the first time you hear
something you kind of like it's in your
Consciousness but you don't really
notice it and it's like take seven times
until you
kind of realize that you have seen it
before or like it's almost like when you
buy a car and then all of a sudden you
see that car everywhere you know and I
feel like that's with pickleball it's
like you know somebody was playing it
and then all of a sudden LeBron James
bryze A Team or like Drew Brees has a
team or Tom Brady's buying a team and
you're like oh this is you know a thing
um but it's been around for a while and
right but it it's having its moment
right now yeah totally it's so hilarious
that you're pursuing this like most
Runners especially Elite Runners would
would not only like not be interested in
that would would like avoid it like the
plague because it just feels like a
recipe for injury like you know what I
mean like there's so many all the
lateral movements and the quick bursts
and all of that like it would be so easy
for you to you know pull a hamstring or
a calf muscle or something like that but
you're like no no do this well and I
think that it's actually good because we
do spend so much time going
straight like and then unless you're
trail running and then you're getting a
little bit more of that but like I think
it's great like I I've noticed that it's
it's made me more limber and it's
um good I think a lot of people that are
in Endurance Sports maybe don't come
from like a rocket sport background or
like a you know ball and Sport
background and so like that for me is
fun too because like growing up playing
lacrosse like I do have those like kind
of skills like what's annoying though is
when you see someone come from tennis
and they're like oh I've been playing
for like two weeks and they can make all
the shots and like they're making you
look stupid because they like just know
how to hit Top Spin like I am struggling
like I really want to like be able to
hit topspin and like
I see someone tennis background and
they're like oh of course you can hit
the Top Spin like yeah I mean you're
you're very humble in saying like I
didn't come from an endurance background
and I don't have any great gifts but
usually people who are in Endurance
Sports part of the reason they're in it
is because they have no eye hand
coordination which is I would count
myself as one of those people like uh
but you're a ball Sports guy first right
developed this huge endurance engine but
also happens to be really fast and can
like hit a ball and play chess like your
neurochemistry like your neural network
is extremely diverse and I'm interested
in like how all those things feed each
other
is that a conscious thing like oh I'm
going to do all these things because
they make me better at the thing that
I'm most passionate about or is this
just like a reflection of your general
curiosity to be kind of a Renaissance
person I mean I think there is curiosity
but I think they all help each other
like if you want to be a good chess
player like you have to be logical like
there's no
like chess is a game but it's really not
it's like everything's known like
there's no like I think I don't you
didn't have any Duke on right like the
professional I know who she is though
yeah yeah like she's amazing but like a
game like Texas Hold'em or something
like there's chance involved like chess
like all the moves are known like
there's no surprises it's like if you
make a bad move like the computer will
tell you you made it back you made a bad
move
um and so like but the same is like
and I think you know this like if you
push too hard in a race
you might know that's a bad move but it
might be the right move because there
might only be 800 meters left right
um but if you push too hard at the
beginning of the race like there's going
to be consequences and I think like and
so many of the things that we do like
and the things that I'm trying to do is
like hopefully they're
impacting what else I'm doing in a
positive way right so like the chess is
helping me with like decision making and
my endurance is helping me with my
chests and then the pickleball is
helping me with like lateral movement
and also just having fun like it's just
really fun and it's like also like I get
to learn like a whole new
lexicon like I get to learn like there's
so much drama in it too like the
pickleballers don't like the tennis
people like I didn't know this was a
thing like the tennis people don't like
the pickleballers and like that's trying
to find courts and like yeah but it's
like
someone and I we were talking it's like
when the skiers first had like
snowboarders coming to the mountains and
they're like but this is where we play
you know it's like why can't we all play
like it's not gonna be worse for you I
don't think like it why can't we get
along and then it's like you know don't
hit it hard at this person because if
you do they're going to be mad and like
so it's been fun to kind of navigate
that landscape also so I think I like to
keep things interesting and fresh and I
think you know pickleball is allowing me
to do that and
um I'm seeing just how much
like
interest there is in it but also like
there's so much skill involved like it
seems like it's you just kind of knock
the ball around but then you watch the
people at the top level like I was just
at a pro tournament this past weekend
with the Yola team and like just
watching them at that level it's like
wow those guys are incredible athletes
well the joy piece like the fun piece
seems to be really important like a
driving force and also like the
friendships in the community right like
the ultra Runner landscape is littered
with lone wolves you know people who you
know like go they're they're going into
the pain cave and having their own
private you know kind of experience with
what it means to push their own limits
and certainly that's part of it of
course when you're running across the
country you're alone a lot but what
animates you really seems to me to be
like the people and the you know the
adventure that happens when you're doing
it in community oh for sure I think that
like when I set out to do the run across
the country like I actually postponed it
because of injury but also because when
I did start to feel better like I didn't
want to do it if
people couldn't join me like during
covid so like I waited until I thought
it was appropriate for people to be able
to come out and be a part of it because
I really did want that Forrest Gump
experience where people are like oh my
God he's coming through my town like I'm
gonna you know call in the city is so
out of control yeah oh my God it was out
of control last week my wife's like you
gotta cut it before you go see Rich
because
uh no I I I really enjoy it too and I
was just
um
yeah that's that's exactly what I was
hoping for like it would move people to
like I had people like flying out from
like Richmond to Indiana to run with me
or
um you know somebody from Indiana ran
with me and had so much fun they came to
finish the last day with me
um and so like just to have people like
have so much fun that they're like
telling their friends to come the next
day or they show up again like I mean
that was just yeah that's really cool
and like to and I had so many people we
had like special Buffs made for it and
like if someone did an ultra with us we
would give them a buff like but we
wouldn't tell anyone so like you know
like I had so many first-time Ultra
people you know that ran their first
Ultra along the journey with me and that
was just like man I can't believe that
you allowed me to share that experience
with you and you were part of my
experience but like I just you know just
to see somebody do something that they
didn't think that they could do so cool
and then the the kind of Downstream
effect of that on their life because
once they've done something like that it
totally expands your perspective on what
you're capable of and like not just as
an athlete in all areas of your lives
well yeah and it's and it's not just
them but then their family knows that
it's possible too like like
my family
when I first started they didn't know
that people could run 50 miles and now
like they know people run 50 miles they
know people run across continents like
they know people run in all different
places like that's what it was so cool
like I think one of my best experiences
like just two weeks ago my son and I ran
a half marathon and like was that his
first half marathon it was his first
half marathon he looks like he's like I
don't know 15 something like 16 16. good
call yeah and so we were just I was like
oh I'm gonna be running the Baltimore
Marathon he's like oh I'll run the half
and I was like wait what and like I just
was like wow this is like
when he was just a little baby I was
like someday maybe we'll run together
you know and like just to have that
moment
um but then to get to share it with like
his cross-country friend Lucas ran and
my brother ran and then we had all the
people in Baltimore because I've run
that race and I don't know seven or
eight times and like just to be out
there cheering for us and like us
getting to cheer for them and
um
just to be part of the community again
like I've missed that during covid and I
missed yeah I missed that chance to
reconnect with people and
um that really feeds me too like I've
said it before like I'm in a like an
emotional vampire like I just suck that
energy in and like use it and it was
great to be out there how old is your uh
you have two boys right yeah two boys
Pierce is 16 and Grant's 13. and so like
three weeks ago we did all did a 5k
together and Grant ran Grant's like been
playing on the freshman football team
and he's eighth grader so like he's
getting you know knocked around by the
freshman and so he started to go and do
some CrossFit with me and uh he did his
first 5k
um like his first legit 5K yeah so and
in terms of kind of parenting active
kids like you don't strike me as a Joe
disena type who's like setting the alarm
up and like dousing his kids with cold
water at four in the morning to get him
out of bed like no you're more of a you
know attraction type like I'm just gonna
set the example all and let them make
their own choice or how do you you know
kind of get your kids excited about
doing the things that that you love
that's exactly it yeah I mean Joe is a
good friend and so like his style is
different than mine for sure
um but yeah I I want them to come to it
through their own means and like I want
to be there like if and I think that was
what's so awesome about like having that
base of Fitness like you could do the
same thing like if your your kids were
like hey we want to run an ultra with
you you'd be like all right let's go
which one you want to do like the
Bulldog one right out back you know um
not asked they have not made that
request yet though but like it's there
right disinterested yeah anyway go ahead
but I thought it was actually funny when
you were saying like you were doing a
promotion for like just eggs and like I
just started eating those and you're
like but my kids actually like eat them
and like I think that that's cool like
that you expose them to these things and
if they choose to be interested that's
great but at least they know it's there
right yeah and so like with our kids
like I want them to know that it's
possible like I want them to know it's
out there and if they expressed interest
then like I want to try to make it
happen for them so like they're super
into gaming and so we got them like
gaming computers and we've taken them to
like professional gaming like
um
like they're really into this uh game
and we went to Montreal to watch like
the World Championships so that they
know what it's like at the highest level
right so like man if you want to do that
that would be amazing like it doesn't
have to be you know what we're into but
we want to kind of facilitate whatever
they're gravitating to yeah your job is
the parent is to kind of fill is to
notice when a spark of inspiration hits
and to kind of fill that Gap and support
that that's the way that I look at it
yeah and it generally doesn't come in
the form that you would like it to come
or expect yeah because it's rigged that
way and there's something cool about
that like you being a beginner's mind
like oh now here's your opportunity to
become a gamer yeah Mike this is your
other professional career that awaits
you well you can do it with your kids
well and and so I have uh done a lot of
gaming and so like I was like the kid
that like broke the Atari when it first
came out like I flipped like Pac-Man and
like uh I used to live live in a group
house and like after I'd finished my
runs I would get on like one of those
little trampolines and like play Madden
for like four or five hours just jumping
on the trampoline you know like playing
my brother and our roommate so like I'm
huge uh proponent of gaming like I think
it's so many people are like oh screen
time limited or whatever and I think
like most of us are on our screens all
the time anyhow and it's just getting
them ready for what they're you know
gonna face in the real world
um and they have to make their own
decisions you know yeah I remember as a
kid we would go to Rehoboth Beach in the
summer oh yeah go to the arcade on the
boardwalk and just spend hours playing
space invader oh yeah yeah yeah
I mean I'm older than you but uh the old
school games yeah totally in the day and
that's that's where my relationship with
gaming begins and ends oh really you
you're not gaming anymore no
[Music]
not even on the Tesla like one is
charging I know that those games are on
there I haven't done that yet oh my god
I've played on Josh's yeah that's so
funny
yeah cool
um all right the the last thing I want
to talk to you about before I let you go
is um
is just the kind of process that you
that you use to choose which goal to
pursue and then the kind of step-by-step
and how you kind of assemble the the the
plan towards achieving that because I
kind of want to leave people who are
watching or listening who are thinking
about a big goal or maybe have never set
an audacious goal for themselves like
how you
um how you kind of Embark upon that
process for yourself and maybe some
tools or principles that could you know
guide The Listener okay yeah I mean I
think
I think a lot of times like my biggest
thing is I always try to say yes to as
many things as possible so like if I get
a invite to a race in South Africa I'll
be like yes uh when I
decided to do the run across the country
I but you have to sorry to interject
yeah like as somebody who's probably
getting invited to a lot of races yeah
you have to learn how to say no right
like how do you choose which things to
say yes to and which things to say no to
right exactly and so like that's what
yeah I was just about to say it was like
when I decided like okay this is my only
focus like to do the run across the
country because usually I'm pretty open
like there's some races that I want to
do or
um you know I have some some goals
um like it might be to run faster or
like to run further or to like you know
try to win my first hundred mile or
whatever it is
um or like you know hopefully get into
hard rock or something right like
um
but when the run across the country it
was like I want to do this then I had to
pick like okay when do I want to do this
then I have to get how do I get everyone
on board that I need to be a part of
this so it was almost like
I drew up a business plan right like so
I was like okay I'm basically gonna form
this
Corporation I'm gonna be the CEO it's a
bad Corporation because we're just going
to be losing money like this is not a
not a you know making money but
hopefully losing somebody else's money
no no no this was this is gonna hit the
sponsors yeah these are expensive
Endeavors yeah no this was this was a
very expensive Endeavor this was a once
in a lifetime type thing
um and I knew it was going to be
expensive and I was like okay but I want
to make sure like
our families on board first right that's
I think in all these things like if you
don't have your team like your partner
or your uh family on board like it's
just not gonna work so like that was the
first thing was like how do I get my
family to be a part of this and want to
allow this to happen
um so once I was sure that that was okay
um then I decided like okay now how do I
get work
and that was what I was really worried
about this like how do I get work to you
know allow me to do this
um
so then once I was like 100 sure then I
brought it to my partner I was like I
really want to do this
um and then I had an idea of like okay
how instead of like oh I just want to do
this I had a like
you have to go through like what are the
the pain points right like what are the
things that are going to stop me from
being able to achieve this and for
running across the country is like how
am I going to finance it like when am I
going to do it
um who's going to be on my team
um how am I going to get work to agree
to it so you just Bank a checklist of
like everything that needs to get done
and then you just start going down that
checklist and then and you have to order
it in a way that like if one thing
doesn't work then you have to figure out
how to make it work before you can go to
the next step and so that's what I did
basically I was like okay I got the
family on board
figured out how we're gonna make it work
financially and like with the time off
then talk to my partner about it talk to
my clients about it uh hired my friend
Mark Cody who came in to help me during
that time
um and I'd wanted the opportunity to
work with him again anyhow so it worked
out perfect
um trained him for a year and a half so
that he was ready for the challenge
[Music]
um year and a half wow yeah yeah so yeah
I didn't want him to come in and be like
oh I don't know what to do
um and then I was still there if you
needed me and I was still working along
the trip so like if there was something
he wasn't sure about he'd just call me
or he's like I need help you're pretty
available well yeah he's running yeah
well and and like I that's why I didn't
want to set like I'm not going to go for
a world record or anything like that
like because if we have a deadline and
there's something that needs to be done
like I would just schedule a day in a
hotel the night before and just work
with the clients to be like hey and you
really need the stuff now so that we can
get this done so that I can you know go
go for a run right
um and everyone was super cool about it
and
um you know there were some days where
it didn't work out the way we wanted and
some stuff had to change and you know I
had to stop in the middle of the day and
and figure it out but like
that's that's why I didn't put a
deadline on it and so I just set myself
up for success and like things are going
to happen and
um you know it's not going to go like
the way you want like I thought I had a
an RV company that was going to support
the run and then of course like the week
before they were like yeah it's not
going to be ready and I was like oh okay
well Cruise America what's up
um and so you just you know put yourself
in the best possible position and then
just keep knocking those things off and
and then for the run it was the same
thing it's like every day wake up try to
be super consistent like the first day
like I wanted to set the tone like we
were at City Hall and like you know
people are like taking pictures and
everything and I was like
we have two minutes like we're leaving
at seven o'clock like the first day and
like you just have to set the tone and
and then each and every day just keep
doing those little things and I think we
mentioned this earlier in the podcast
but if you you know keep doing the
little things the big things happen but
if you start thinking about the big
thing and all the things that can go
wrong like you just get stuck or you get
paralyzed yeah right yeah or you're
thinking about uh the flower when you
should be focusing on the root yes you
know focus on the roots flower takes
care of itself focusing on the roots are
the little things that you're doing
every single day the watering and the
tilling tilling of the soil yeah well
and you just keep stacking the little
things and that like big things happen
when you do that yeah
um how do you convey that to your to
your kids
just by just by your actions or do you
actually like sit them down and say
Here's how you accomplish goals no and
how does that go over no either dad uh
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah wait can you
take your airpods out right
um no I think
I think
and you probably see this too is like
your kids like no matter what you say
your kids are going to do what they see
right and so if you're modeling things
that you want them to do or achieve like
they they pick up on that much faster
than if you say like Hey we're gonna sit
here for 20 minutes and talk about what
it means to accomplish big things uh and
then I try to just engage with them as
much as possible and I think that that's
one of the biggest things like
I am really
missed them when I was gone and I don't
want to miss all these opportunities
like I had a chance to do a race in
Bhutan in October called the Snowman
race it's one of the places in the world
that I haven't been that I really want
to go and they wanted us to be there for
25 days or something I was like I'm
gonna miss like four cross-country meets
and five
five football games and like all the
time in between and I've already missed
too much time this year and and I think
you know this but I and I don't know if
this is true so like if you do a fact
check like some I know your podcast
doesn't do that but like you can I don't
know I should probably fact check this
but like 90 of the time you're gonna
spend with your kids is before they're
18 so like if you don't spend that time
now it's not coming back and so I want
to be as president as I can be and so
I've just been around and and we'll just
you know our son will be like hey you
want to go play Murder ball on the
trampoline and I'm like yeah let's let's
go do that and then while we're out
there we're just talking about like hey
have you done your project in you know
chemistry or history or whatever and
um
oh you need to my our son's doing a you
know they go to this kind of cool school
called HB Woodlawn where they have a lot
of independent
um study and and Direction and that's
pretty cool it's really cool and it's
like a public school and it's just
Lottery it's super lucky that our kids
got into it and
um he's doing a project on tourism and
so like we went to the the library just
the other day like I got them library
cards and like they had library cards
but of course they aspired during covid
So like
um but I was just there to be able to go
with them and that's when I saw all
these cool books about travel like these
routes that I haven't seen before like
now like I want to run like the Silk
Road and stuff because I saw it in this
like book but like just being around to
help them you know with photography or
something like they're doing
these cool projects and I just want to
be there and help as much as I can and
I don't think like sitting down and
being like hey you know you should make
a checklist like yeah that's that's just
you get the eye roll yeah but at some
point the Bhutan trip or the similar
type of Adventures perhaps you bring
them with you right oh and that's what
we've done their whole life so like
they've been like one of our big goals
is to get them to all seven continents
and they've already been to six
continents as 16 and 13 year olds so I
didn't realize yeah you had traveled
with them oh yeah so they've they've got
friends in New Zealand they've got
friends in France and like they're
actually doing a solo trip uh this
spring together to France as a field
trip and my wife's like oh we should go
and I'm like no no they should go by
themselves for them yeah yeah so like
yeah next year we're gonna try to hit
Antarctica and that'll be their seventh
continent nice yeah that's exciting yeah
so they're World Travelers cool and I
think that they've learned so much I
think I mean I don't know if you've had
the chance to take your kids around the
world with you but like there's much
more that can be learned from you know a
trip to Japan where you just get to see
so much unique stuff or a trip to France
or an opportunity to be 100 like yeah I
mean my brother and I talked about this
like he's taking his kids to Portugal
and like they're gonna miss a couple
days of school and I was like any time
that yeah anytime that we've like gotten
one of those like hey you know your kids
need to be in school we're like okay
like they're learning a lot in in the
real world too yeah
um I just think yeah there's so much to
be gained from the worldliness of
traveling to foreign locations for kids
that that impressionable of an age and
like missing school because of like that
kind of a broadening experience like it
doesn't even you know yeah equate well
and what I think is awesome is like they
know that there's different ways to do
things like they know like that you
don't always have to you know have
the easy easy meal or they know like
sometimes the train doesn't come and we
have to figure another way out to get
there or you know sometimes your bags
don't show up or that's why you only
carry carry-on creative problem solving
yeah the fly exactly or like yes your
mom and dad are going to give you a a
you know a caffeinated beverage at two
o'clock in the morning so that you can
get off the plane you know like oh yeah
so they've are yeah you probably
shouldn't put your iPad in the back of
the airplane so that we have to go back
to the airport the next day because you
lost it you know like yeah those things
all happen all that kind of stuff man
yeah
um cool well let's just end this with uh
with uh you know a little
um sort of uh inspirational words of
wisdom for
somebody who's uh who's who's inspired
by what you just shared and is is ready
to go and is thinking about it doesn't
have to be their first running race but
trying to do something hard
yeah I mean I think the biggest thing
for me
um and I think for a lot of people is
just finding something that lights you
up I think you mentioned this earlier
but like if you don't have something
that you're a little bit scared of or
you're a little bit intimidated about
like it's going to be hard to like wake
up at 4 45 in the morning when the
covers are warm and
um
but if if there is something that you
can find that you're interested in
don't be afraid to go for it like I
think signing up is like the first step
and like it doesn't even have to be a
race it could just be like hey I want to
you know try to go to my local Trail and
and run it and and I thought you
actually had somebody on
like not that long ago that was said
like the 12 hour walk from your front
door yeah Colin O'Brady yeah and it was
awesome like I was like that's exactly
what
would be a great first step for a lot of
people is just go like somewhere close
and just do something unusual or
take the train to the other side of town
and like figure your way back to your
house like it could be like I have a
friend that started a race
um called Eco Trail in Paris and you
basically like was like I'm going all
over the world to run like why don't I
just have a race like I go train I take
the metro out of Paris and then run back
to the Eiffel Tower you know like
when I first started running like one of
my big runs was I'd run down to the
Washington Monument and just be like wow
I can't believe I get to run like to the
Washington Monument or like the Lincoln
Memorial like
um and that's like maybe seven or eight
miles from my house but like you know
seven miles there seven miles back all
of a sudden it's 14 miles that's a
pretty big thing you know and it could
be that or it could just be like hey I
want to you know go to Starbucks and you
know run home from there or walk home
from there and you know it starts small
and then
um but if it is something like big like
I think do it man like there's so many
people that I see like wait to do
something big and then something gets in
the way or they don't have the health to
do it anymore and like
it's it's cliche and dumb but like sees
the sees the opportunity sees the moment
because you never know what's gonna
happen like I have so many friends that
retire and then
they're like oh I have you know dreams
to go to Greece or like I'm gonna spend
all this time with my family and like
something happens and it it doesn't work
out that whatever happens yeah I mean
you you have to begin you have to
develop an inclination for Action even
if those are small steps
um I think a lot of people get paralyzed
because they're waiting for their life
to you know come into some sort of
alignment where it all feels perfect and
makes sense and it generally isn't you
know no life doesn't work that way
typically if it does good for you but
the other thing I really love about your
example and your story is is you're
somebody who has a passion who pursues
that passion very vigorously but that
passion doesn't come at the expense or
the cost of like family community career
like you didn't quit your job you know
like you have a you have like a you know
like in some respect like a traditional
kind of job career yeah and that's very
important and creates the stability for
you to be able to do these other things
and there's something really kind of
like grounded about that that I like
because it's not this irresponsible like
oh just you know let go of everything
and like go into the you know go like
you know be like Kung Fu and like you
know walk walk into the Wilderness
because like I have a passion it's like
we live in the world you have kids and
responsibilities and bills and all of
that and yet you still figured out a way
to pursue all of these interests that
like light you up and you've been
successful at them but most importantly
they've given your life like joy and
meaning and I think that's really kind
of you know it's powerful to be somebody
who who is as Elite as you but also like
so relatable in most of how you spend
your time yeah I I hope that that is is
is what people take away like it's um
I think it's it you know it's hard like
it's it's not easy I mean I think like
you know I was jealous at times when I
was you know you probably know a guy
named Anton kapitzka and like he and I
would like battle back and forth and I'd
be like dude he's just living in a but
he lives a totally different like that
well yeah exactly I mean he might as
well be living in a cave compared to
like the way that you live your life
right but like
it doesn't matter when you show up to
the start line it doesn't matter like
you just do the best with what you have
right and so like if you're worried
about what someone else is doing like
that doesn't work like but like
there are so many people that go and
they do like I'm gonna do two marathons
a year and I'm gonna you know build up
and like that's that's what my life's
gonna be and like that's great that I'm
glad that you know there's people that
can do that and they have really great
performances but that's just not not
what lights me up and gets me excited
and
that's not my life yeah I got you and
but I did have that I mean I did have
that debate with myself like do I want
that life you know at a various points
like do I want to walk away from this
and and be a full-time athlete and like
what does that look like and I'm I'm
happy that I I didn't do that I'm happy
that I tried to see if I could make it
all work because you know you probably
had this too is like so many people say
like it's not gonna work and it's not
like people trying to be negative it's
just like for a lot of people it doesn't
work and I'm glad that it has for me
yeah well you seem happy yeah I'm uh
fulfilled in the choices that you've
made and uh it's good talking to you man
I appreciate it and I wish you well I'm
at your service oh man when it comes to
running on the moon let me know oh dude
yeah I need a car maybe that might be
worth having you back to talk about
dude I would love that yeah any any time
man I'd love to hang out and do this
again some point yeah awesome well it's
it's it's really fun to kind of watch
your journey from afar and it's it's
been an honor and a pleasure to meet you
and talk to you so thanks thanks a lot
cheers peace
[Music]